you know you know when you think about
cia maybe maybe movies have done this to
us and i've asked this you know from
other
ci agents you think about the profile of
a cia
agent you know foster kid you know that
doesn't have any
attachments to anybody you know doesn't
uh maybe isn't
married doesn't have kids parents
relationship wasn't the best you know
are those criterias that they take into
account
today or maybe back in your day or is
that just fictional
what we see and reading movies and books
yeah no that's a good question
you know frankly it's it's a little bit
fictional what do they want they want
they want well-adjusted stable uh
individuals confident um
some self-discipline uh common sense
you know they're looking for kind of
exactly what you would think right
because you're given a great deal of
responsibility depending on again look
the agency is made up of a lot of
different
career paths right there's a lot of
different uh
requirements in there and so it's a very
diverse range of uh
capabilities and skill sets everything
from finance experts
to scientists engineers um
and then you've got you know people like
me
so it's it's an interesting uh
organization because it's a lot more
uh it's a lot more diverse both in terms
of skill sets required and also just the
people
than uh the movies ever make it out to
be so you were there for 17 years what
are some of the craziest assignments you
had
that you can actually tell us about
yeah well that's that that is the
problem you just kind of your caveat at
the end there is sort of the
the restriction look i i've got a very
good relationship with the organization
in part because you know i keep my yap
shout about
uh sort of the important things um and
one of those is kind of getting too
specific i will say that
uh i was in operations and i touched on
everything from
you know counter-terrorism to
counter-narcotics during the drug wars
to
um you know sort of insurgency
operations
um and there's uh
there's there's in the operations side
of the agency
there is always an opportunity to walk
away from something
uh at the end of the day and think to
yourself you know nobody else is doing
this
nobody else right now on this planet is
engaged in this sort of activity
and and that is what kind of keeps you
fired up because
you know those moments can be separated
by pretty great distances you know you
could spend
six weeks sitting in a safe house
somewhere waiting for something to touch
off
um and then you've got a moment of
something really interesting from an
operational perspective and then you
know you go back to filling out
paperwork to explain how you lost some
gear and
you know uh you know your expenses and
uh
you know it's so it is it's if they
actually made a feature film about what
really goes on i think it wouldn't
necessarily be as exciting as a jason
bourne
adventure it wouldn't be yeah so you
know i've had i've had a
nick mckinley on uh where he did some
work in the past i've had
jonah mendezon who was the former chief
disguise
officer who had you know the the head
the skies of i think president bush or
somebody else that he should be open
it was believable i had piranto on i had
jane woolsey on
i had shabbat from mossad on just you
know there's a lot of folks from
different uh
spaces that that i've had on and i've
interviewed with jonah mendes said
invest i said what
makes for a great agent she said
somebody
who's extremely driven extremely
charismatic
extremely curious extremely competitive
but
doesn't need to celebrate his victories
i thought it was such a unique way of
describing
a great agent would you say that sounds
pretty right on what a great agent would
be
yeah her and her husband tony who's
passed on great great people um and
and she's super smart and and i think
she
she kind of nailed it there yeah i mean
look you're not doing it for the money
you're not doing it for the salary what
is the salary bug what is the salary i
don't know
it's it's uh it's in line with the
government uh services you know the gs
pay scale
so which is amazing right if you think
about it
uh look when i started out and i started
out at a very interesting time in
sort of agency operations um
i believe i was making seventeen
thousand and five hundred dollars a year
now when i look back on that and i think
about what
what we were happy to do for seventeen
thousand five hundred dollars a year
yeah you're not doing it for the salary
you're not doing it for the pay you're
not what you're worth right
yeah you're not doing it for anybody
patting you on a bag what year was it
what year was it when you were making
17.5 oh [ __ ] that was
uh that was the early 80s right i got
started i was in for
almost 20 years and uh so
you know that's uh you know but but
you're happy to do it right because
they honestly make you feel by the time
you finish up
all the training depending on what
you're gonna be doing uh
you know i was ready to walk in front of
a bus for you know the director and
and uh the president so uh
but you do uh if you're doing it for the
right reasons it's not
because you're looking to uh you know
get that constant reassurance or
constant pat on the back
right you're clearly aware that you're
doing it for something bigger than that
and and that's uh honestly god that's
those are the folks that i always worked
with and ran across and
met and dealt with whether they were my
my uh superiors or
you know i mean to do
cia the job of a cia agent is
one of the requirements for them to help
you become a ci investigate to see if
you love america
is there got to be a like a certain
level of patriotism to be an agent or
not really
i i would hope so i would
i would like to think that's the case
and i would like to think that that
shines out
look it's um part of it
part of it is a bit of a self-selecting
process right
um you know if you're applying to the
agency then
theoretically um you know you're you're
you're kind of already in that camp
right unless there's there's something
else going on that's that's somewhat
unusual so yeah i think patriotism is an
important part of it you have
and again i i was one of those people
who uh
never really you know i never imagined
myself to have all the information that
the
the uh the headshed or the top floor you
know the seventh floor has
and uh and so i never was one of those
people that would sit around and
question uh tasking or you know uh
operational assignments and and uh i
think that's a useful thing because you
don't have all the detail
you don't have all the information
you're a tiny little part of the of the
machine
when you're out in the field working
whether it's in paramilitary operations
or it's in
in you know uh narcotics carbon
narcotics or
terrorism operations you're just a small
piece of the action right and all that
that
you're doing is getting put in the same
pot as
information coming from a variety of
other sources or or
you know and and and then people that
are
paid to make those decisions take all
that and figure it out but
i you know so maybe i approached it from
a fairly simple perspective i don't know
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye